now if you are struggling against the
Sicilian con vation then not to worry
because after watching this video you
are going to equip with a tricky line
which you can really employ in the
tourament
[Music]
practice after E4 and C5 the Sicilian
con vation arises with the following Mo
order Knight to F3 E6 D4 C captures D4
Knight captures D4 and now black plays
this typical idea
A6 trademark of the Comm
variation okay here we are going to
continue with moroy bind setup and that
start with C4 so idea is you put the
bind on the D5 square and accordingly if
you look at the database there are few
popular choices
es in our case it doesn't matter because
black can play either of this Boom the
resulting position reach to the same
Junction so for example Knight to F6
Knight to C3 Bishop to B4 and at this
position by far the most popular choice
is Bishop to D3 defending the E Pawn
however my recommendation is you play
this very tricky move and that is Queen
to D3 not only Defending Your E Pawn but
setting up a nice platform for our
upcoming tricks and
traps okay it's time to look at the
database and obvious enough black has
tried these three options and we are
going to look each by turn and find out
how we are going to surprise black and
get the early winning
positions the first move I want to
consider is bad move namely Bishop
captur C3 so Black's idea is he's
destroying your Pawn structure but in
return he has some now huge problem on
those dark squares and if he thinks that
D6 resolve all his problem which is in
fact database chop Choice I'm afraid
it's not enough as after Bishop to A3
and
castle White has this lethal move E5 and
that more or less get the winning
position you are losing the D pawn and
as for the engine the base sequence goes
as follow Pawn takes E5 Bishop takes f8
Queen takes f8 and after our Knight to
B3 yes indeed at just 12th move of the
game white obtained The Exchange and
with some accurate play this game can
definitely convert it into the full
point the second move I want to consider
is Queen to C7 which has a clear idea to
stop our eii advancement and against
this I am going to show you one of the
most trickiest line in this variation
which start with
A3 and the point is after Bishop takes
C3 it looks like white has to take back
with the pawn as his E4 Pawn is hanging
but guess what nope we are going to take
with the queen setting up a very trappy
platform of course if black Castle here
then we can defend our E Pawn with a
very good game so more or less if you
look at the
database black has exclusively take this
Pawn thinking that o oops white has
blunder but the matter of fact is after
this black is by force losing the game
so before I move on guys I want you to
pause the video and find out that killer
sequence which can finish off the
plaque did you find it let's check the
golden Mo here is night to
B5 what a move and the point is first of
all black cannot take over a queen in
the view of Knight takes E7 King to E7
and after Knight takes 8 and the Moon
Knight to E4 if you count the material
it is white who emerg with an extra Rook
just within the opening
stage so that's the reason why Knight
catcher C3 is completely out of the
equation at this position that means
more or less black has to take this KN
but then our task is very simple First
We Take on G7 attacking The Rook black
has to save The Rook now you play Bishop
to F6 once again attacking the rook and
threatening Checkmate so by force black
has to defend the Rook with Queen to C5
and we reach to the point where if you
play just one right move then game can
be finished
instantly do you want to try out please
pause the video and go ahead buddy I'm
showing you right now just look at
this
F3 and after this no matter however
black regles he get a completely lost
position okay black has three choices
but neither of them are one walking
number one if you play Knight to F2
looks like counter attacking yook but
unfortunately after White's next reply
that is B4 that Queen is an overload
piece and of course black has to save
the mate so Queen to E7 and then what
else you grab the piece and the fun
doesn't end here guys because after some
natural moves Pawn takes C4 Bishop take
C4 and in the next turn we are going to
take the Rook no matter whatever happens
so for example Knight to C6 Queen takes
f8 Queen takes f8 Bishop takes f8 and
King takes
f8 the dust is clear and at the end one
can easily say that it is white who has
come out with a whole exchange of and a
completely dominating
position
okay what about the more natural move
Queen to have2 check but it is just one
check as after King to D1 now you have a
bigger problem and that is we are
threatening a Checkmate as well as
trying to capture your knight and black
cannot defend both the threat so by
force the queen has to go back in order
to protect the Rook but that leads to
the same story F captures E4 B captures
C4 now of course you take the rook and
after the forcing sequence Queen takes
Bishop takes King takes and Bishop takes
C4 what else again and again it is wi
who get winning position with a clear
exchange
up last but not least engine's top
recommendation here is to play the Moon
Knight to F6 and give back the pece but
then you have some huge problem on the
dark squares and after Rook to G8 I like
to show you a model game from the
database where white continue with Pawn
takes B5 look at those dark squares
extremely weak so Black Thought hang on
I need to exchange the queen but white
was completely on a driver's seat so of
course he denied it and the problem from
the black side is his pces cannot come
out and we are attacking on this poor C8
Bishop so black response is almost
forced he has to go Queen back to d8
afterwards I really like White's next
move and that is Bishop to G7 planning
to come on
F6 and even though it looks so simple it
is very very deadly and in fact the game
finished after just two moves black
plays
D5 white plays Bishop to F6 and after
Queen to
D7 Rook to
C1 and what else the clear resignation
as the poor C8 Bishop did not see a
daylight before he
died
last but not least what happens if your
opponent continue with Knight to C6
which is database CHP choice and in this
line I'm going to show you one of the
most high-profile tra and that goes with
the following variation Knight takes C6
Pawn takes C6 now you exchange the queen
and then play your trademark move
E5 where if the Knight moves anywhere
then we can support our E Pawn with the
F Pawn and we get a space in the center
with the misplace King but as you look
at the database the Top Choice is why
not play Knight to E4 and double attack
the C3 Knight looks very obvious right
and yes indeed this is exactly white ons
as black has straight away fallen into
white trappy territory and the trappy
business start with A3 Bishop takes C3
Pawn takes C3 and of course black has
given up the bishop pair and weaken the
dark square but the point is he has won
an important Pawn so it looks like black
is doing good but the big time problem
is after White's next reply
A4 black is in a huge trouble in some l
L we are going to trap that Knight so
sooner or later Black Knight has to
escape with the E4 Square But Here Comes
the whole point we play Bishop to E3 and
our task is very easy on the next move
we want to play F3 and would you believe
that can actually trap the centralized
Knight the best black can do over here
is to play F6 so at least he is giving
the Escape Route for the
night but white says no sweetie you
cannot Escape so the H4 is a logical
response whereupon black is forced to
find the only move which can keep him in
the game now before I show you a model
game just look at the engine Evolution
here it says black is completely losing
and to highlight what is the problem I I
have picked an high-profile game from
the FED database where both the player
are in excess of
2200 and here black find the accurate
response namely fi so his idea is pretty
clear if you play F3 then my knight can
escape from the G3 Square so white
prevent this by playing Rook to H3
indeed threatening F3 something black
cannot avoid it so he continue with King
to E7 and his idea is after the move F3
he want to deliver this counter punch
F4 okay white just took the pawn and
allowed the Knight to escape but see
yourself how pathetic black position can
become after this Rook to G3 attacking
on G7 King to
F7 now comes another attacking move
Bishop to E3 so Knight has to go back
and after this the star move of the game
is AI completely paralyzing black on the
queen
side well I think black is already
frustrated in this position as he
continue with Knight captures E5 a big
blunder as after this white instantly
get a completely winning position and
that start with Bishop to E5 Knight to
G6
H5 Knight to f8 Rook captures G7
whereupon after King to E8 and Bishop to
D3 sorry but I can't stop laughing here
as blacks every piece on the back Rank
and just look at the engine Evolution it
says it is just a matter of time before
black has to give up the
game so I think this model game give you
a great illustration how dangerous white
position can become if black fall for
our dangerous
trap that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high-profile tricky line
against the Sicilian con
variation remember after our Queen to
D3 no matter however black plays against
all this line as I have shown in this
video we have some nasty tricks on the
table and the good point I like about
this line is even though let's say your
opponent doesn't fall for tricks and
traps white still obtain a decent
position and all the chances in the
upcoming middle
game well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment and I will see you in my next
episode very
soon bye and take
care